an hours-long police standoff come to an
end in green valley happened near paseo
verde and green valley parkway victoria
saha has been covering this incident all
evening long joining us live with what
we know now
the seat is now cleared at fountain hill
community but earlier today it was
packed with dozens of police vehicles as
they negotiated with a suspect inside a
house who we are now learning police
found that suspect dead inside but
during this time residents were forced
to be outside
police swarmed into this quiet gated
neighborhood monday afternoon as they
tried to make contact with an armed
robbery suspect there were snipers
outside and
yeah
the swat cars pulled up neighbors
describing to us the chaotic scene they
were seeing right from their window we
kind of peeked out because we weren't
too sure what was happening and over the
bullhorn they were like get back in your
house like just stay there police doing
everything they can to make the suspect
come out from our house you could hear
boom boom and the
robot i guess blasted the door open
and so that's why we got on our bikes to
figure out what was going on viewer
video showing us police got loved ones
of the suspect on the phone to persuade
him to come out
police say earlier in the day there was
an armed robbery it was neighbors who
tell us the suspect was in the house
hiding the standoff ended nearly four
hours later as police say the suspect
took his own life
henderson police has not said anything
else about that robbery that the suspect
was connected to earlier in the day they
also say nobody else was hurt in this
incident reporting live from henderson
tonight victoria zaha live local now